most people believe that technology can
help developing communities but it can
also widen divides I grew up in Sri
Lanka in a developing community and then
I came to the US for my Higher Education
so I've seen both of these worlds and
the potential that technology has to
bridge them rather than divide them this
is why we started tech ridge road here
at carnegie mellon university to work
with developing communities and to build
technology that can empower them to
realize their vision of progress when
we're talking about development we're
not just talking about people having you
know food clothing and shelter we're
talking about a community being able to
realize its goals and chart its future
and this requires being able to
participate actively in a global economy
and in terms of technology technology
that means being creators as not just
consumers of technology in tech bridge
world everything we do starts at the
grassroots we first find a partner and
work with them to understand the needs
of their community a project doesn't
even start until we've identified a need
where we think technology can have an
impact we're really excited that in the
first four years of tech ridge world
we've already established partnerships
in over a dozen countries including
Zambia indias colombia Ghana and many
more
a good example for our approach is our
Braille writing to the project one of
our former students Nidhi kalra worked
with our partner who in this case was
the mattress school for the blind in
India to jointly identify technology
that can help visually impaired children
one of the problems the teachers told me
about was that some of their students
were too weak to write and some of the
younger ones didn't understand the
concept of rails so I asked them to send
me a video of their students writing and
they did and immediately it was clear to
me how complex this problem was but I
was also able to identify right away
ways in which technology could
potentially play a role many came to me
with the idea of using something
physical some new input device to allow
students to learn Braille by having the
computer interact with them for the next
year Tom and I worked on improving the
hardware and the software and getting
input from blind community in Pittsburgh
and researchers at CMU until we had a
device that we felt pretty confident
that we could take to India and so in
the summer of two thousand six I boarded
a plane and headed off to Bangalore our
first field test was very successful and
we learned that we could improve this
tool in many different ways so our
students worked on improving the design
of the tutor they built a new curriculum
and added several new things like
mathematics and new languages in Braille
and then we were ready to feel test this
again so we built a new partnership with
the syphilis cool for the visually
impaired in Zambia and we also sent our
students back to the mattress school in
India we decided to develop a couple of
games the first one was an animal game
the Braille tutor would throw out an
animal sound to the computer speakers
and the students would have to write
down using the Braille tutor what animal
that was so we saw that the Braille
tutor could also be used to teach other
subjects such as general sciences in
general knowledge in a fun and
interactive way we've seen how the
Braille writing tutor transforms the
lives of these children and because of
its low cost our goal is that every
blind child in the developing world will
have access to these
but the Braille writing tutor is just
one example we have several other
projects that have similar impact in the
communities we work with these bridges
that we build to developing communities
also have life-changing impact on us and
on our students the realtor project was
a specific problem in the specific
solution but it really reinforced my
feeling that I want to continue doing
this type of work for the rest of my
life I hope to work on similar projects
in the future that you know wherever I
go there are organizations like
engineers Without Borders which does
similar work and hopefully there's
something like tech bridge world at
wherever I end up I really would like to
see a world which in which people
participate or more equal footing and so
the experiences I've had in tech bridge
world in terms of working with partners
in terms of working with technology and
implementing and innovating new
technology for new settings is going to
be invaluable for me people may not
realize that the developing world is
also full of creative and
entrepreneurial minds this is why what
we do is so important because we build
bridges that bring together people from
the developing world and the developed
world to jointly create technology that
improves our lives and our world to hear
more about our work and find out how to
support our efforts visit w WT r org
you